-Now, I thought I'd share some
of my favorite
dog Halloween costumes
from you guys.
Here we go.
This first one's from
@Pelin3356.
Her dog costume is,
Pawlice Officer.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Pawlice.
-That's pretty cute.
Yeah, Pawlice Officer.
-At least it wasn't paw lice.
[ Light laughter ]
-This one's from @Andresgs12.
His dog's costume is Puppywise.
Ooh.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-He's in, like, a little sewer.
I mean, come on.
-Dogs love it.
[ Laughter ]
-This one's from @Xraytech88.
I'm assuming they are
an X-ray technician.
-87, yeah.
There's 87 of them before him.
[ Light laughter ]
-No, I think maybe 1988,
maybe they started?
-On Twitter?
I don't think Twitter
was around in '88.
-But X-ray technology was.
-I guess you're right.
X-ray technology --
Perhaps it's Marie Curie.
[ Laughter ]
-This one's from @Xraytech88.
Her dog's costume is
Pawnald Trump.
Look at that comb-over there.
Yeah, there you go.
Just got to comb it.
That's an easy costume.
-Yeah, that's easy.
Just a comb-over,
and you're done.
- [ As Trump ]
I've got enormous paws.
[ Normal voice ] Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, this next guy is my jam.
This is from @Brussellssprout,
and his costume is
Sproutie the Grouch.
Look at this.
-Aw!
-Oh, my gosh.
Look at that dude.
-It's a good --
-Scram!
-Sproutie the Grouch.
This one's from @3Chisue.
Her dog costume is
Jimmy Ruffett.
Well, there you go, yeah.
Party dog.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Like Spuds McKenzie.
-This one's from @Bschout509.
Her dog's costume is
Pughetti and Meatballs.
Aww.
-Oh, there's a --
-[ New York accent ]
Forget about it.
[ Normal voice ]
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This one's from @TracedThurman?
-Oh.
-Traced.
Traced.
-Traced?
-Traced.
-Traced, like tracing
a piece of paper,
like you trace this?
-Like Thurman was
traced by the --
-Like, maybe on the phone?
Like a traced phone call?
Or trace as in traced paper.
-Hold on.
-[ Imitating phone ringing ]
-Hello?
-Oh, sorry.
-[ Imitating phone ringing ]
-Hello?
Hello?
-[ Woman's voice ] Hello, yes?
-Oh, hi.
Did I call you?
-Yeah, you just called me.
Oh, I just -- Is this Thurman?
-Yeah, it is.
-Oh, cool.
I'll call you right back.
-Okay.
--[ Imitating phone ringing ]
-Hello.
-Denver police department.
-Yeah, did you trace the call?
-Yes, I did.
It's coming from
inside the house.
-No!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Coming from inside the house.
-So, Thurman was --
-Oh, my wife's name is Thurman,
I apologize, officer.
-Yeah, he's not theremin.
-No.
@Tracedthurman.
His dog's costume is
Furry Kreuger.
[ Applause ]
He licks you in your sleep.
And this last one is
a mind bender.
This is one of my
favorite costumes.
This is from @Dearmanali.
Her dog's costume is
Toto as Dorothy.
Ah, that's meta!
There you have it.
Those are our "Tonight Show"
hashtags.
To check out more of
our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.